you know if you listen to a complex
piece of music or at least this is my
experience with complex music just
sometimes the first time I hear it I
don't really like it and I go down I
don't I think I also don't understand it
I actually can't hear it you know maybe
a musical genius could hear the whole
thing instantly you know say uh Franz
Liszt they say he could sight read
anything on the piano first try so you
know some people are so intelligent
musically that it's incomprehensible and
I'm sure they hear things just find the
first time they hear them but then what
happens for me is that if I listen to it
a couple more times there are pieces
chunks of it that start to fall into
place that I can follow and and you know
I can see the beauty sort of shine
through those and then eventually the
whole thing links together and then I
can listen to it especially if it's a
complex piece of music many many many
times and the more complex and probably
the better the piece of music the more I
can listen to it but if I listen to it
enough at some point then I've had
enough of it and that's all very strange
phenomena because one of the things you
might ask yourself is what exactly are
you learning while you're doing that you
know it seems like you want the music
it's something like you want the music
to be just exactly the right amount of
predictable and unpredictable and if
it's too unpredictable then you can't
understand it and if it's too
predictable it's boring and so it's just
like the conversation that way it's
actually just like life as well you know
because you want things to be
predictable and stable and you want
things to be unpredictable and
interesting and the degree to which you
want each of those is going to depend on
the time in the context and also on your
own intelligence and temperament so now
I'm going to tell you a bunch of stories
and give you a bunch of a number of
pieces of information and hopefully
they'll pick together now I think the
reason that this information is always
being transmitted in story and image
form is because it's very very difficult
to transform them into articulated like
into fully articulated explanation it
isn't really how it works you know we're
not really accustomed to thinking about
the idea that there are certain forms of
information that and that that are valid
forms of infor
nation that can't be transmitted
verbally but of course if you think
about it we all understand this deeply
because well I can give you a bunch of
examples the first example is that when
you speak not only do you speak in words
and phrases and sentences and paragraphs
but you also speak melodically and in
fact part of the reason that you can
understand melodies and that they make
sense to you is that what artists have
done is separated the melodic element of
speech from the semantic element and
then played with the melodic element and
the melodic element tends to carry a lot
of emotion and intent and so if you're
listening to someone speak you can tell
when they're being ironic you know
because they raise an eyebrow and their
voice changes slightly even though they
might be using in fact they are using
exactly the same words and in fact
someone who's very good at being witty
or ironic will set the situation up so
that you can barely tell that they're
joking and the better they are at that
the tinier the hit they give you that
you can still catch on to the funnier
the situation is so so we know that
information can be transmitted through
nonverbal channels it even happens
during speech and then of course we
understand that music presents to us an
intimation of meaning that's very
difficult to fully grasp and music for
me has always been a ineffable
phenomenon in some sense because it
carries the information of meaning in a
manner that can't be rationally
dismissed or that people are interested
in rationally dismissing so you even
punk-rock nihilists listen to punk rock
nihilistic music and they you know they
find that meaningful even though they
don't believe in me me and you know in
some sense they're victims of their own
rationality because they do believe in
meaning or they wouldn't be listening to
the music but they can't understand how
they could possibly believe in it so
they're rational mind has dispensed with
the idea and sometimes that's people
dispense with the idea of meaning for
lots of reasons partly because of
because it's inevitable in some sense
with sufficient rationality but also
because
because it's always useful to look for
the underbelly of things because it also
justifies not bearing any responsibility
for your life and not necessarily what
that can be a very desirable side-effect
of a particular ideological irrational
belief and then there's dance of course
and dance is even more ineffable than
music although it's often paired with
music you know honest and if it grips
people if you see a remarkable dance
performance well part of it is that
you're sort of thrilled and excited
about seeing just exactly what the human
form can do you know because perhaps
partly because you're human and when you
see someone extending a certain ability
far beyond the norm then it expands your
sense of what a human being is capable
of so there's so there's that there's
just the pure skill element and then
there's a novelty element because often
if you watch a particularly good dancer
there's things they do that you haven't
seen before that you didn't know anyone
can do and that's pretty fun and then
often the dances is joined with the
music and the body is expressing what
the music means and even though you
can't tell what the music means you can
tell that the dance is expressing it and
see I think what happens there is that
music represents the patterns of being
it's actually because people think of
music as a non representational art but
I think that's wrong I think it might be
the most representational art is that
being is made up of layers of patterned
layers of patterns constantly interact
interacting and hopefully in a
relatively harmonious way and music
music demonstrates that mimic that in
some sense abstractly and then the dance
is an abstract representation like
people adapt to the patterns of being
and the dancer adapts to the pattern of
music and so it's a it's a symbolic it's
an embodied display of the place of the
person in the cosmos and you can you can
also make that case when you see people
dancing in pairs because you can dance
alone or you can dance in pairs and
that's basically standard
human adaptation so and music is
interesting too because one of the
things that you'll notice is that
there's always music in a movie almost
always there's the Audrey movie that
doesn't have it but it's quite marked
when it's absent you know the movie
feels a lot more cold and clinical
though it can work but we accept the
idea that music can be used to fill in
the missing context in a movie without
he's never questioning it right like
it's very strange if you think about it
that you go to a movie that is doing at
least at least part of its function is
to portray reality in a realistic way
but there's a soundtrack playing in the
background all the time and you don't
you know it's so useful and so
appropriate that you don't notice how
strange it is that that's okay